to uh give awards and film documentaries
a category I'm personally addicted to we
have two of the stars of the phenomenal
Star Trek the motion picture captain now
Admiral Kirk of the Starship Enterprise
not a motion picture but in person
William Shatner and his stunning
navigator Persis Khambatta
the nominees for the best feature-length
documentary films are best boy only
child motion pictures incorporated IRA
wall producer generations on the wind
more than one medium David a Vassar
producer going the distance National
Film Board of Canada Paul Cohen and
Jacque Bob a produces the killing ground
ABC News close up unit Steve singer and
Tom Priestley produces the war at home
catalyst films Madison film production
company Glenn Silber and Barry Alexander
Brown producers and
the winner is best boyy IRA water dish
so what's a nice Jewish boy from Queens
doing in a place like this this is a
great personal honor for me and it's
particularly wonderful because it's
associated with a film of which I feel
so very proud best boy took three and a
half years to make but it was very much
a labor of love and it tells the story
of my 52 year old cousin Philly who's
mentally [ __ ] and his parents who
near 80 and about how he finally comes
to separate from them as their lives end
and his life has to go on the film has
been seen mainly on the East Coast and
with documentaries it's not always easy
to get people to come and see the film
and if this award will help more people
to come and see it then it will really
be doing its job I want to thank the
Association for the help of [ __ ]
children in New York City for their
support of the film and for the
wonderful work they did with Philly I
want to thank the entire crew but in
particular Tom McDonough director of
photography who gave his sensitivity and
intelligence and understanding and made
the film much more than it would have
otherwise been I want to thank my
cousins Francis and Norman my aunt and
uncle were no longer alive and pearl my
uncle max and most of all I want to
thank my cousin Philly who gave me the
opportunity to do the most important
thing I've ever done in my life and who
has continually reminded me how very
delicate and beautiful any single human
life can be thank
I'm glad he didn't have a larger family
the nominees for the best short subjects
and documentary films are day of ardor
film Scott J stole Popov I hope for your
salad on Charlie Papa productions in
cooperation Donald a Connelly and James
a messenger nails National Film Board of
Canada Philip Borsos for works in
tribute to an artist James films in
corporations soldier Tyrell remember me
dick young producer and the winner is
Paul Robson tributon artists RJ to air
producer
thank you thank you all my life I've
wanted one of these and to everybody
that helped with the film especially
Paul Robeson jr.
you